hello and welcome today we're gonna look
at what's in a name the need to nip nips
by Daniella Witten Elina farik Animus
Rhiannon Kumar and Jeff Dean this a bit
of a special paper as it's not an
academic topic the paper in fact is
about the change of name or other change
in acronym for the conference neural
information processing systems
previously abbreviated nips but now for
the first year this conference has been
hosted under the acronym Europe's the
people here on the paper are not the
organizers of the conference they are
advocates for the name change and the
paper basically outlines their arguments
and a bit of description of what
happened so there are also pretty big
names in the community so it should be
interesting to see what they have to say
the paper is pretty short it's three
parts three pages and we're gonna go
through it and yep let's jump into it so
have it over here alright so the first
part of the paper basically describes
it's called what's what's all the fuss
about
it basically describes why a name change
was necessary in in their perspective so
they say in machine machine learning
like the rest of Samsung suffers from
severe gender imbalance low retention
rates for women and so on they also
describe the me to movement increased
awareness of sexual harassment faced by
many female researchers pervasiveness of
sexual harassment at computational
conferences and they reference an
article here I want to kind of show you
this article it's this article here so
if you haven't seen this yet I encourage
you to read it it's pretty horrifying to
read but it gives you an idea of what
people talk about when they say sexual
harassment is a problem is pervasive at
conferences and so on so
yeah just I don't want to go into this
specifically just go ahead read it and
you know see what people are talking
about that I think it's important
context to understand where people are
coming from so they go on to say have
more more subtle acts of gender
harassment they defined in in this
report this includes like sexist
hostility crude behavior and so on have
gotten less public attention on the
nonetheless gender harassment is
extremely pervasive this direct
contributor to the challenges faced by
women in the stem field in this article
we argue that nips the former acronym of
the ineuron from issue processing
systems conference constituted gender
assman towards women so that's what
their arguments basically about so the
acronym led to basically had had its
part in gender harassment towards women
basically led to an environment where
women could not feel comfortable at this
conference so here's this that their
description in popular slang the word
nips is an abbreviation for nipples
furthermore it has historically been
used as a racial slur targeting people
of Japanese origin but will will not go
into this deeper because that's kind of
a historic use of the word the the
current use of the word in fact is the
slang for nipples and so we'll focus on
that they say at first glance the fact
that a machine major machine learning
conference shared its name with this
Lang is an unfortunate but unimportant
coincidence and it really is a
coincidence I think the the conference
name has been around for a longer than
this Lang has been kind of popular this
long word has been popular so it really
is is a coincidence many other
conferences have same coincidences like
cult for example maybe actually that's
even less a coincidence than
here they say in fact one might hope
that members of the machine learning
community are sufficiently mature that
the conference's name is unimportant
right that's basically what what
everyone would hope like maybe people
don't even notice and if they notice
maybe they'll have like a two-second oh
that's you know that's the other word
haha but then we basically just go on
with our lives and no one cares too much
so that that's kind of the ideal
scenario and they they acknowledge that
here it's it's really it's really
important that they do they say all
right
unfortunately this appears not to be the
case and they detail a few examples here
at the 2017 conference Elon Musk made
inappropriate jokes about the acronym
participants were Luke t-shirts I think
once said my nips are np-hard which is
kind of a double computer science joke I
guess and there was a pre-conference
event named word I can can't probably
say out loud without getting some sort
of strike so so you can clearly see that
even though the kind of original name is
going SCID ental and you know one would
hope that people are like you know just
putting it off the adults about it there
have been there have been jokes there
have been you know t-shirts made and you
know you can say the name collision is
is certain is not like is unintended but
I think this word here is very intended
so I think the the the main argument
here one of the main arguments is this
really
first of all creates an environment
where certain people don't feel
comfortable I creates kind of a
sexualized environment second of all and
more broader sense it's just
unprofessional as as a community
especially since the kind of community
is booming we want to represent machine
learning to the wider world one one
could say okay it's you know it's just
in professional that
that we kind of bring intertwine these
things it doesn't make a good impression
they say furthermore reminders of the
unfortunate acronym everywhere online
searches for the acronym led to not say
for work content the hash tag in EPS is
devoted to pornography if you misspell
the conference website you get to an
adult site and I think this yeah this
further goes into the the argument that
it's just a non professional appearance
towards the outside it's unfortunate the
conference that's been here longer but
you know still there's a need to do
something about it and I largely agree
with these arguments that these are good
arguments to make for for a change of
name alright this paragraph down here
it's a bit of a we'll go into that later
it's not very connected to the arguments
made here so well it's more like
connected to what's been happening so
we'll go into that later so people have
been circulating these arguments and
calling for a name change for a while
and then the the board of the conference
and IPPs board made a survey surveying
the attendance of the last five years
conferences whether or not the
conference to change its name and the
the next section is dedicated to how the
survey turned out and what the response
of the board was so actually let's first
go to the go to the discount this
decision by the board so here is the
press release this is a press release
after the survey results had been you
know collected so they said our survey
was returned by about 2,200 people here
and as I said have attended nips in the
last five years of the male respondents
about twenty eight percent are in favor
of the conference name change of the
female respondents about forty four
percent are in favor of a name change
forty percent preferred existing name
sixteen percent expressed no preferences
in fact let's go look at the detailed
results which they have down here
so you can see overall there is a big a
big slant towards not agrees our
negative two is strongly disagree with
the name change well positive two is
strongly agree so you can see there's a
big slant towards the not agree if you
split this by gender of respondents then
you can see the basically the mail
distribution is that slant while the
female distribution is a bit different
as you can see here the first thing it's
mostly towards the extremes so there are
more people strongly some doing saying
something then non strongly saying
something to up to either side and the
second of all it seems very divided and
very evenly divided so in fact if you
look at the numbers if you count the the
disagrees and agrees you'll find there's
a slight majority in the agrees there is
a slight majority in the disagrees if
you only consider the Strongs but but
ultimately these numbers are pretty
close so that there's there's people on
either side feeling strongly and there's
about in this survey about as many on
either side so that's basically the the
the outcome of this here I find very
interesting some quotes from respondents
who had the opportunity to put quotes to
put a put like a comment and these are
quoted from these comments so they say
for example this thanks for considering
a name change I'm not personally
bothered by the current name but I think
the gesture will send a much needed
inclusive v in the right direction I
mean okay they one person says if you
were up to me I'd call of this nice but
symbolic gesture use whatever time money
and energy to make actual changes then
someone says please please please change
the name it is sex
racist slur slur I'm embarrassed every
time I have to say the name of the
conference this feeds into the
unprofessionalism argument the next one
I find very interesting it says as a
woman I find it offensive that the board
is seriously considering changing the
name of the meeting because of an
adolescent reference to a woman's body
from my point of view it shows that the
board does not see me as an equal member
of the community but as a woman first
and a scientist second this is extremely
interesting so this is this is one of
the people who was a female respondent
and said strongly disagree with the name
should or disagree with the name change
I I mean I can guess so
the we've only heard so far that the
name or the acronym is offensive to
women but here we have a woman saying
that the consideration to change the
acronym is actually offensive to her
right that's that's that's very special
it understandable right I can I can
understand why that that happens I can
understand the the argument made here
I'm that this woman feels like okay it
shows me that basically my gender is
important and not really my being
scientist it's you know it's an argument
the next one goes into the same
direction says I am a woman I have
experience being harassed by male
academics and I would like this problem
to be discussed and addressed but not in
this frankly almost offensive way so
another person saying basically that's
that's the changing the name is is kind
of is the almost offensive and it's not
the right way to go to achieve these
results it's another one saying I'm in
favor of the name change but this is
cosmetic so you've basically people
coming from from all from all angles
giving their opinions and you can
clearly see why there is especially in
the in the female respondent group why
there is a divide
and so the board overall said the
following why the system oh never mind
the board overall said the following
here after extensive discussions the
nips board has decided not to change the
name of the conference for now the poll
itself did not yield a clear consensus
on a name change or a well regarded
alternative name further they state
instead we asked a community support in
implementing concrete steps to improve
the inclusiveness of the conference so
these are described down here they have
a number of changes to make the
conference basically more inclusive so
they basically said okay so the the name
change that the name change survey was
inconclusive
and they clearly say whatever we do here
regardless of which decision we take
we're failing to accommodate the
opinions about half the women in the
community which is true this is clearly
what you can see from the results from
the quotes right so basically what they
say is will not change the conference
name for now we'll implement these steps
because what they've I can guess what
they felt was okay even the people
against the name change were in support
of making the conference more inclusive
so they basically say okay we do these
things we've strengthened their code of
conduct we've have to inclusion
diversity chairs we have an inclusion
Town Hall we have childcare support
gender inclusive restrooms and so on and
so on mentoring breakfasts for women and
other minorities so they take these
steps concretely and they say this is
what we do and even further if you look
at their page on diversity and inclusion
which I have here they say here on the
top in addition to hosting diversity
related event the conference also making
sense structure changes include new code
of conduct we've already seen and
in-depth discussion of the potential
of changing the name of the conference
so in total what they're saying is we
didn't we've done this poll it came back
inconclusive which you've I think has
been clearly demonstrated that will not
change change the name of the conference
for now and will do all of these other
of these other things right down there
and at the conference will hold the
meeting and discuss the name change so
we could maybe potentially change it in
upcoming years right I think this is a
really sensible decision by the board I
mean given this data given all of that
this is probably the most sensible
decision like let's take concrete steps
the name change seems to be you know
debatable so let's actually debate it at
the conference with the actual community
so that was the basically result of the
poll let's now go back to what the paper
has to say about this so here's that
paper again and they say in order to
collect data about the machine learning
communities feelings about the
conference name the conference board
sent out a survey to people who have
attended the conference during the past
five years our serving however serving
only conference at these results in a
very biased sample of a much larger
community of potential machine learning
researchers bias arises due to the fact
that some people who are made
uncomfortable by the name or by other
aspects of the machine learning culture
may have decided not to enter or to
remain in or not remain in the field
I've chosen not to attend the conference
so basically are saying well if you only
ask this one group of people right then
this other group of people you know
doesn't have a chance to make their
voice heard and there's basically bias
because in this other group of people
the people who have not attended the
conference they would would have a
severely different opinion from the
people who have attended the conference
so first of all
I think this can be a valid point here
of course always if you ask one group of
people and exclude another one you
there's there's if the if the group you
ask and the target group which here it's
really unclear what it is I guess it's
the machine learning community
considering going to the conference if
those don't overlap then you you will
introduce some sort of bias and they say
okay eyes could come from the fact you
know some people who actually are
affected by these problems of which this
name is one they may have you know not
attended the conference because they may
have left the field because the the
gender harassment is so pervasive and
they just didn't didn't stay and so on
so I think this can be a good point but
the problem I have with it here is that
it's simply stated without anything it
simply said okay there is bias bias
arises and my question would be how much
is that bias of any data like any data
on this
you can't just criticize these that the
survey for being biased and and then not
provide actual data and how many people
are there who are made uncomfortable by
the name or have left the field in where
I've left the field because of these
things and is it really viable to to
count them in I guess okay we can argue
it is but how would they have responded
to this we've clearly seen that a lot of
affected people that even have
experienced harassment are not in favor
of the name change so in this case I
would really like to see some data on on
how on how much this bias is right and I
cannot also say it's not it's not that
bad of a decision to what the board did
to send the survey to the last five
years attendees I think is a very
sensible choice
if you want to gather the community's
feelings towards these kind of things I
mean you you can't just ask the entire
world because the entire world is not
the machine learning community so I
think the this is a very sensible
decision to ask last five years
attendees and if you have real evidence
that this causes a notifiable like a
significant bias then we could
potentially correct for that bias but
without any date on that I think the the
asking last five years participants was
completely reasonable and one of I don't
really see how you can do a much better
job without much much more manual work
and I want to make this point a bit
clearer on how hard it actually is to do
that by pointing to the response to this
so here's a tweet thread by one of the
authors of this paper after the
conference decision came out she
basically tweeted out this protest snips
I am starting this new hashtag please
retweet if you're in support of the next
conference changing its name so
basically kind of launching a Twitter
campaign a Twitter hashtag under this to
come you know get into a conversation
with people about this people could
express their support
she also that was a misclick she also
here made a change.org petition to
change the name so a petition basic the
petition is here the text of the
petition basically says something
similar to the to the what we've already
seen including there is a that the
criticism of the survey and as you can
see here about 2,000 people have signed
it
so I mean a Twitter hashtag is all good
you know you can do that a petition is
all good you can do that but it's a bit
ironic because a change.org petition
literally anyone can sign this and in
addition to that there's only one option
you can only say yes you can't even say
no right so and even more who's gonna
see the change.org petition it's gonna
be the social media followers of these
people right so basically you have now a
you have it now what's basically a
survey of the social media network of
people in favor of changing the name
where there's only one option to respond
I I find it and so I've gone through
here the people who actually publicly
associated in aim give a reason for
signing a lot of these they you know
they give some argument why they've
signed the petition but I've tried
searching these people for any sort of
academic track record and in my sample
I've come up with between 10 and 20
percent of people who somehow have an
academic track record so this is I mean
certainly a valid thing to make your
voice heard and to show your numbers and
but I mean look at this as a bot signing
twice hello Jack Nelson and Richard Chee
very nice but so basically I'm not here
to criticize petitions but what I want
to say is you can't like criticize this
this poll so hard for being biased and
then launching basically an own poll
that's even more biased and even more
non representative of the community to
me that's that's kind of ironic and just
goes to show how hard this is and my
argument would be it
not that unsensible of a decision of the
board the way they did it and if you
have again if you have data to actually
quantify the bias here then it's viable
to go and correct for that all right so
to take octagon to analyze the survey
results conference board simply noted
that of the 294 women surveyed the
number who strongly support or support
the name change is comparable to the
number of women who are strongly opposed
to a post
however this analysis implicitly assumes
that one person's feeling of discomfort
or marginalization as a result of the
name should be given the same weight as
another's person's preference for the
status quo this amounts to giving the
same way to false positives and false
negatives of course we learn in an
introductory statistics course that
false positives and false negatives
should be assigned weights dependent on
context in this context we feel that a
much greater weight should be given to
the views of a person who feels
marginalized as a result of the name so
up here I find this a bit strange they
say this amounts to keeping the same way
to false positives and false negatives
to me
the false is here a bit confusing
because it seems to me it's it's simply
giving the same way to negatives and
positives there's I don't think there's
a need to dress this up in statistical
lingo here it's simply we give the same
way to people who responded positively
and people who responded negatively I
think that's that's it there's no false
of course we learn in intricacies to
this class that false positives and
false negatives should be assigned
weights depending on context in this
context we feel that a much greater
weight should be given to the views of
person who feels marginalized as a
result of the name I would I would say
to this it's
the problem for me it's these are this
is one of the things that were you at
really first and you say like oh yeah
this makes sense but first of all it's
framed extremely one-sided it's framed
as all the people who are for the name
change like they they feel discomfort
that they feel marginalized and the
people who are against the name change
they simply and here specifically they
they talk about the women group so in
argument they're all affected the people
against it simply prefer the status quo
but we've clearly seen in the in the in
the press release and we'll go over to
that now these quotes here we've clearly
seen that the offense and the
marginalization happens on both sides so
here this is as a woman I find it
offensive that the board is considering
changing the name it shows that the
board does not see me as an equal member
of the community but as a woman first
and the scientist second I mean this is
almost the textbook definition of
marginalization and the this is clearly
happening on the other side as well so I
think the framing here is extremely
dishonest and one-sided and there is
given basically that the the side that
we just seen in this quote is given
absolutely no not even a mention that it
exists it's simply framed as this side
is marginalized and oppressed and
discomforted and the other side simply
prefers the status quo but we've clearly
seen yeah this almost this fits exactly
this definition it's just one person's
feeling or discomfort or marginalization
as a result of the name it's just as a
result of the name change second of all
I think the the bigger problem and this
goes into the statement down here to
state this last point more explicitly an
issue adversely affecting
minority of participants should not be
decided by a majority vote again
something at first you say oh yeah that
makes sense
but if you think about it this is a
really really outrageous statement and
the reason is it's it's it's outrageous
is if the mud if it's not majority vote
if it's not one person one vote then
someone has to decide who gets to vote
and who doesn't and if more so
specifically here someone basically
needs to decide who should be given what
weight in a vote right you need someone
to decide this and here you can say well
it's easy it's just the women right
because they're affected by this but
they go further they say well it's the
women who feel discomforted and
marginalized who should be given more
weight than the ones who simply prefer
the status quo but then you have to have
someone assessing whether someone is
really marginalized and discomforted or
simply prefers the status quo and it's
not like an environment where there is
kind of a my sexist undertone isn't also
discomforting or can also be
discomforting to men to men of any sort
or people of of any sort of gender it's
just not clear that the fact that people
should be given different weight in in
crafting an opinion I mean this this can
be true if you have like some clear area
of expertise but in this case it's
really unclear and the fact is if it's
not majority vote you need someone
deciding the weight and the someone
deciding the weights automatically
decides on the outcome of the vote and
then why do you need a vote in the first
place basically up here they say yeah we
feel the weight should be aligned
this and that but down here there is no
more we feel its be an issue adversely
affecting the minority prisons should
not be decided by majority vote they're
basically calling for a dictatorship in
this case and I'm gonna guess like
everyone has the opinion that
dictatorship would be an awesome idea
if the dictator were me right that's
that's what everyone thinks of course
and that's basically the argument made
here but it's not it's not true and
there's some really really disturbing
implicit things in here and maybe I want
to quickly go over how I think a
democratic decision works so imagine you
have a person and the person has a
decision to make for or against in this
case the name change right and the
person must decide on one of these two
things on a let's say on a continuous
scale but it doesn't matter what what
this with this stuff up here basically
implicitly assumes is that the person
looks at themselves and they think well
am i personally discomforted or
marginalized by the name or the climate
it creates no then I'm obviously against
the name change because it doesn't help
me or another person go and I personally
affected yes well I feel discomfort
immersion eyes well then I'm obviously
for a name change
so the basic assumption here is that
people simply vote purely their own
egotistical interests and that's that's
it so basically if you're in one of
these minorities then you'll vote for
the name change because it affects you
which we've already seen is not it's not
a given that people vote that way and if
you're not in this then you know you you
vote against but you're not affected so
your vote shouldn't count it's
completely untrue what people do
especially smart people and I believe
the machine learning community
cysts largely of these what they do is
they'll make a list of arguments
argument one argument two argument three
argument for everyone has the same
arguments everyone's heard the same
arguments if not then maybe there's some
work to do in actually getting arguments
to people but that's not the same as
weighing the people differently you get
the arguments to the people and then you
weigh each of them equally why because
what every person does is they say okay
argument one is maybe it's
unprofessional right name is
unprofessional
all right how important is that to me
give it a wait wait one cool that's
really important to me I'll give you a
big weight argument to some people feel
really discomforted if you're
marginalized by the name it creates a
bad environment for them how much weight
am I going to give to that right so
people can actually consider other
people's feelings and other people's
problems and decide on what's the best
also for them in their own mind so
they'd give it away too and then there's
maybe two arguments against some given
these wait three wait for at the end
what you have is you have argument I you
will sum it up by the weights W I J you
will sum it up over all people so
basically now and this will give you
like a final number a which is either
positive or negative if it's positive
you do the name change if it's negative
you don't do the name change if you do
this over all people what you've
basically done is you have just
determined these way things here by a
democratic process you've crowdsource
the weighting this is exactly what these
people say up here right we feel we feel
that you're not false false positives
false we feel that positives and
negatives should be assigned weights
dependent on context
so the positive and negative arguments
in this case are assigned weights
depending on context but the weights are
crowd sourced to the community right and
each person this who participates in
that each person who participates is one
more brain power in a complicated
decision that no one basically no one
has the authority just to just decide
for themselves so these people are
calling for a different weighting this
is the way to do it the Democratic
majority vote is the exact way to
determine these weights what these
people basically are is no no we should
determine the weights we who know I'm a
bit corny here but this is basically it
still it's two alternatives either you
do democratic process
one person one brain one vote and that
will give you a crowd-sourced
crowd-sourced true weighting of the
arguments what the community feels or
someone needs to decide some one needs
to side by force basically and that's a
dictatorship so these are the choices
you have and clearly now you can maybe
understand why I say this is an
outrageous statement because to me the
dictatorship option is not an option
note that I'm not saying that democracy
can never be wrong or the majority can
never be wrong but in fact it's the best
system there is can be wrong but
anything else will undoubtedly go more
wrong so that's my point here all right
so that wasn't maybe a bit ranty but
let's go on a false choice and a
minimization of a real issue so they go
on to say what they think of the
decision that the board made in response
to this so up was how they analyzed the
poll and now it's the decision
in announcing their decision not to
change the conference name conference
board expressed commitment to implement
concrete steps to improve the
inclusiveness of the conference and they
list them here and they say we sincerely
applaud conference board for these
efforts okay I yeah I think the
community feels like that as well
however the wording of the decision
implied the need to choose between
changing the name of the conference and
taking concrete steps to improve its
inclusiveness I don't see that at all
say this was a false choice there's no
reason that the board cannot do both yes
there's no reason that they couldn't do
both and I believe we've read this
together before I don't think the board
ever said that there was a choice
between one or the other I think they've
said very much the opposite let's go
back I think what they mean what here is
the word instead so here they say we
won't change the name and then here's
they say instead we ask for the
community support and implement increase
EPS I think this this must be it because
I don't really see any other way you
would ever think that and the reason is
this here they say will not change the
name of the connivance for now on
another page they say we'll discuss the
name change at the conference and then
here the instead I think what is meant
is instead what we will do right now is
these things will discuss about the name
change but what we will do right now
which was basically not the the real
problem in the first place the real
issue raised was the name so instead of
that issue we'll do these other things
which we feel the community wants I
think that's the I think there's no I
think everyone reading this comes to the
same conclusion after after reading that
but so I really don't see how you you
can say that this is kind of presented
as an either/or by the board I don't
think that at all
and you decide for yourself I believe
the real real the real crux here is the
for now and the promise to discuss at
the conference which if you can see here
in the paper
is never ever ever touched right they
they make it basically seem that the
board has decided to not change the name
and that's it which is completely wrong
they've clearly stated their openness to
a name change they want to discuss it it
was just inconclusive so they want to
basically not do anything rash and then
half the community is against it anyway
so they want to discuss it I to say that
this is basically that that the wording
implied the need to choose I don't see
that um but you know you decide for
yourselves the board suggests in the
name change would only be symbolic and
so on would have no real consequences so
that this these are some of the
arguments basically made in the quotes
as well but you know did the fact that
the name change would only be symbolic
and so on these are all things you could
actually discuss at the con at this
conference meeting you could even
correct for your for your poll right you
could invite people who have left the
community to represent those you could
invite new potential researchers you
could give everyone their voice and then
actually listen to all of them I think
that's a very sensible decision by the
board and I think this is misrepresented
here lastly to say another argument
though not explicitly mentioned a number
of machine learning research told us
that changing the name of the
continually do too much confusion in the
community while we understand we
respectfully do not share it I mean this
is it's basically an argument against
the name change I think it's also a
point worthy of discussion right the
they say they say we respectfully do not
share this point yeah okay they don't
share it other people do it's a point of
discussion we could you know you could
actually discuss it at the conference
but I actually agree with the authors
here I think changing the name will not
have a big impact on he kind of
recognizability of the conference
especially now down here we'll actually
get into what actually happened in
November the in response to extensive
public backlash The Conference Board
announced a change to the official
conference acronym tuner it's they say
we are pleased provides this provides a
reasonable compromise so in my opinion
this is it as far as solutions go this
is a good solution right the the nur its
acronym I think it's it's it's cool you
don't have to change the name of the
conference itself you simply change the
acronym which you know was the reported
problem in the first place
I think the all the new papers will like
people will still recognize the old nips
acronym or the new conference it will be
clear that it's the same thing and I
think this is a very good a very good
new name and I think people will get
used to it pretty quickly it also you
know to saner it's it's it's also rolls
off the tongue easily so it's as far as
solutions go I like it further they say
however the work for the conference
board is far from done oops we encourage
the board to continue its efforts blah
blah blah so they say okay you have to
do more than just change the name and so
on
they say together these steps will help
ensure that the Nerds conference retains
its place in the forefront of machine
learning research while also creating a
welcoming environment for women and
members of other represent groups on
other underrepresented groups we all
hope that to me the problem is that it
how this how this went down and if we go
back and look at the actual press
release
of the name change they say here dear
members of the neural information
processing systems community something
remarkable has happened in our community
the name nerves has sprung up
organically as an alternative acronym we
were delighted to see it being adopted
indeed one forward-thinking member of
the community purchased nerves calm
described sighs purposes hosting
conference content under different
acronym until the board catches up we've
caught up we're considering alternative
acronyms when the community support for
nurbs became apparent we asked all
attendees to respect the solution from
the community using new acronyms so
basically have rebranded the entire
conference about a month before the
actual meeting asked all sponsors all
invited companies asked all invited
papers to rebrand the acronym to me this
the wording here is VIP is a bit funny
like something remarkable has happened
in our community has sprung up
organically and now we'll just adopt it
it seems like it seems like much less of
the fairy tale to describe here but the
actual like there's a there's a mob with
pitchforks around your house and this is
like the first kind of straw that you
can grab to to make them calm down and
also know that some companies have begun
pulling out funding for the conference
so I think this is really this was
really you know much more backed by
force and and back yeah what they say in
the paper extensive public backlash so
loud screaming basically then this this
kind of the name has sprung up
organically and has been adopted and
seems much more bit forceful to me it
would have still been a viable path the
most valid have to actually wait for the
conference and then have that discussion
and then
if indeed this name nips would be would
be presented as a good alternative and
you know people would be fine with that
then you could still make the name
change for last for next year I think
this this would have been a good
alternative my fear now is this has been
extremely rash extremely forceful as as
I've said also accompanied by with like
by withdrawal of funding that I believe
these things usually provoke a backlash
and that's really something that I
wouldn't look forward to so I hope that
this con that this paragraph down here
is true that actually we will see a more
welcoming environment for everyone but I
believe things like this tend in society
to have sometimes very opposite effects
of what's intended and so I hope this
does not produce a backlash I think
having had the actual discussion in
doing things non rashly would have done
much more in the direction of preventing
such a backlash so this is the end of
the paper
so to recap they basically say the
acronym was was inappropriate which I
agree with
they say the survey was bad which I
could believe if there was data they say
that an issue adversely affecting the
minority of participants should not
decide by majority vote which I
absolutely disagree with and then they
say the board has basically stated this
as an either-or decision which is I
believe not true and misrepresenting or
maybe I've missed something it's always
possible lastly I want to get to this
paragraph in recent months a number of
women including some of the authors of
this article who publicly expressed
support for a change of the conference
name have been relentlessly trolled
harassed probably
he wasn't even physically threatened on
Twitter reddit other online forums much
of this harassment they say has been
anonymous and typically has had an
extremely gendered tone furthermore some
students have reached out to us the
author's lamenting the fact that they
felt unable to openly express their
support for renaming the conference due
to fear of bullying or retaliation by
faculty advisors or others in position
of power this I believe is really bad
the fact that people can't speak out
about something like this without being
bullied or harassed or having to fear
for their careers basically is is bad
and I would really discourage everyone
from engaging in such behavior verbal
abuse physically threatened I mean
that's I mean to one point you can say
all right if you've been on the internet
for a longer than a week then this
probably has happened to you if you have
had any sort of serious discussion on
the internet but you can also say that
doesn't make it right so I believe it's
it's really important to separate what
is you know harassment basically from
actual disagreement and criticism and
please engage in the latter do not
engage in the former my problem with
this paragraph it's again it's very
one-sided
it's basically stated here some students
have reached out to us lament in fact
that I felt unable to openly express
their support for renaming the
conference due to fear of bullying
retaliation by faculty or advisers of
other in others of position in power to
me
I'm you know I'm gonna say this probably
happens on both sides what you know one
could argue where it happens more but
this very much happens on both sides of
this issue and it's real shame for both
sides basically I think anyone should be
able to express your opinion
to demonstrate that here I'll show
another Twitter thread by one of the
authors of this paper where basically
this is a thread where she posts
screenshots of conversations basically
people reaching out to her saying
exactly that like I can share my I've
trouble sharing my opinion I get mocked
from my opinion I can't do so publicly
because I fear you know from my from my
faculty and so on but then there's also
this one here where a person wrote an
email to the author basically saying
they disagree with her and I I've read
this email I don't you know I don't
agree with the arguments here made but I
can say that the this is not verbal
abuse it's not personal attack it's not
physically threatening it's actually
quite respectful disagreement there the
person actually goes through length to
say how respectful they are how much you
know how much this is meant as a as a
disagreement on factual terms and
further what they say is that they wanna
be anonymous maybe you see it on the
very bottom for example I haven't done
too much to anonymize myself but I ask
you to respect my wishes of remaining
anonymous don't try to figure out who I
am
further up they state basically they
want to remain anonymous because they
fear for their latter for their later
career right they fear of a backlash up
here wish to remain anonymous as I'm an
early in my career someday we may work
together so basically they say here I
disagree here's why I disagree and they
wish to remain anonymous because they
fear for their career right so this is
almost like this is very much here
feeling unable and will will go feeling
unable to openly
express their indicate support against
renaming the conference due to fear of
bullying or retaliation by faculty
advisors or others in position of power
so this author here is obviously a real
person in position of power I mean very
famous senior researcher and this person
basically says I'm afraid and I can you
know that that's why I'm anonymous and
the way the author responded here as you
can read read is what an anonymous
coward of course I will do everything to
guess you and it's it's difficult to to
kind of put this off as I mean even if
it's I don't know how it's meant right I
will do everything to guess you in the
least it means she will try to figure
out who that is right and she doesn't go
as far as saying that she will then
basically either you know remember that
name in case of any future thing or
share it or whatnot but it's certainly
you can't argue that this is a real
deterrent for other people to even
anonymously voice their opinion to if if
this person announces I will do
everything to gas you to me that that
shows that this fear that we discuss
here is very much present on both sides
and it's absolutely not okay if if
either side reacts by basically my
basically retaliation or even even the
the possibility of retaliation and I
believe everyone should be able to say
their opinion I respect really everyone
even like these these authors here it
clearly took a lot of effort and a lot
of a lot of beating basically they say
they've been relentlessly trolled
harassed verbally abused even physically
threatened this is just really bad and
have lots of respect for them
saying their opinions stating their
opinions anyway I think everyone should
be able to do that without these things
happening so to everyone
watching I encourage you to not engage
in these things and that alone will
probably make the environment much much
more inclusive and nice for everybody
irregardless of of affiliation so that
was it for me for this paper it's a bit
longer it's a bit ranty if you agree
disagree let me know in the comments I
yes and other than that have a nice week
weekend
whatever you do bye